So this required some guesswork, since we hadn't actually run
any examples this large. But if you understood the examples
we saw with the smaller inputs, you should have been
able to guess that it would take about a second to
do a look up for a table with ten million keywords. And the reason for this, if
we look at the previous executions, we saw, based on the keywords in the index,
the time increased linearly. So, when we had 10,000
keywords we measured the time as 0.0009 seconds. When
we had 100,000, we measured the time as 0.009
seconds. We didn't measure any times beyond that. The
suggestion from looking at this is, well when, when
we increased the number of keywords by ten, the
time also increased by a factor of ten. So
maybe if we could guess, that if we had
a million keywords, it would probably take about 0.09
seconds, to do a look up. If we had
ten million, the time would take 0.9 seconds, which
is close to one second. If we had a
100 million, then the time would take about nine seconds.